TSR square actually stands for talented
scholars resource room located in 16 159
it's a room that's available 24/7 to any
undergrad at MIT to come used it's like
a wonderful spot it's kind of in the
middle of campus right in between all of
the freshman classes so it's a perfect
spot to stop when you have an hour
between classes you can come in here and
like study they didn't come in here and
kind of like hang out with people and
see if they're working on the same
things as you are and help each other or
you can also like set up one-on-one
appointments and like get help in like a
certain area or certain classes that you
need oh okay yeah we do midterm exam
reviews final exam reviews so it was
like a lot of open free time to just
like play with problems and figure out
how do I actually solve these problems
if you have a question I'll be right
here you can work on your own we can
work together on something it's up to
you it is drop-in so students don't
really need to sign up for peace of
nights or exam reviews it was really
nice knowing that there was always
somebody that I could ask for help from
just by coming to this room in order to
request a one-on-one appointment
students actually utilize the office of
minority education website and then they
can have a one-hour session with the TA
here in the the TSR square room so
really just offering students the
opportunity to make sure that they feel
confident and that they're really
prepared for the subject and the exam
that they have coming up all of the
services and the programs that we offer
a free of charge
sabari assets and basis aside from the
academics the TSR square is really a
study lounge it was definitely a
positive environment where students
really feel that they can come and just
kind of like take a break from
everything thinking to recharge a little
bit migrate just got a lot better after
I started coming here to TSR squared
just come check out a piece at night all
of our TAS are very helpful so even if
you have a question that you feel like
you could maybe figure out on your own
just come in it'll be a fun experience
you'll definitely learn a lot and you'll
make really great connections that I
think will go beyond just your pset or a
concept that you might be struggling
with or like some feedback
[Music]